well I teach two courses that are LGBT
related introduction to queer cinema is
the first course and in this course it's
basically a study of canonical films
both sort of mainstream films and
experimental films and the periodization
actually starts with at the very
beginning of cinema in 1895 film by
William Dirksen who was working in the
Edison labs with early sort of sound
experimentation Vito Russo who wrote the
classic book on gay cinema called the
celluloid closet calls it the gate
brothers but it's an example of how the
course tries to complicate these films
bringing in contemporary theory and also
locating films within a historical
social political production history so
this film actually is a film that shows
two men dancing while Dirksen himself is
playing the violin and the two men are
actually two sailors on a ship where
there would be no women and the song is
called the song of the cabin boy so
there's a way that it actually captures
a history of same-sex environments
spaces during the late 19th century
early 20th century where men felt like
they could be more intimate in those
spaces and so to call this the gay
brothers doesn't quite capture a kind of
history that they themselves would not
identified as gay probably identified as
heterosexual but in these spaces they
would have felt like it was easier to be
as I say intimate and dancing you know
in sports and and sort of other events
so it's an example of taking sort of
contemporary theory as I say and looking
at a lot of the classical texts but
trying to
problematize them and not allow a kind
of present us reading to basically
monolithically position these films so
the course starts there and runs through
as I say a number of canonical texts to
do this kind of reading that's both
historical and also theoretical some of
the films that we look at our Queen
Christina with Greta Garbo with Alfred
Hitchcock's rope some like it hot
directed by Billy Wilder the boys in the
band directed by William Friedkin desert
hearts which is a lesbian romantic film
independent film in the mid-1980s into
what's called the new queer cinema where
a number of directors Gus Van Sant and
Gregg Araki Tom Kalin were making films
such as my own Private Idaho swoon and
even other films like poison come out of
what's considered to be a new queer
energy that's challenging mainstream
cinema and and trying to come up with
films that are sort of coming from
within gay community and gay
subjectivity instead of industry films
which have been sort of exampled by
Queen Christina rope and boys in the
band and then the course ends with more
contemporary films like Brokeback
Mountain The Kids Are Alright and pariah
a very recent film but mixed in with in
these feature films we put what's being
produced with larger budgets through a
lens of telling a story narrative
against an experimental film which is
often made by queer artists who are
talking about you know their own sort of
response to being gay or lesbian and how
this is either accepted or demonized
within the public sphere
the dominant public sphere so you get
filmmakers like Kenneth egg or Jack
Smith Andy Warhol Barbara Rubin and
others who are making shorter
experimental films that suggests an
alternative cinema to this more
mainstream cinema so this is the films
that we look at and the way that we
approach these films and intro to queer
cinema the other course that I teach is
post-war queer avant-garde cinema which
mainly focuses on experimental film and
it looks at experimental film from 1945
to 1968 and racist the issue that a
number of the classical experimental
films influential films made during this
time period were made by gay men and you
have filmmakers like and I mentioned
those with the intro to queer cinema
course but like Kenneth Anger Jack Smith
Andy Warhol but there are many many
others
Willard Moss Gregory markopolos Curtis
Harrington charles bolton house Jose
Rodriguez Otero and then a number of
actors in the cinema Mario Montez and
Taylor Mead that there's a sense that a
major part of experimental cinema in the
u.s. is coming out of queer community
queer subculture and to think about what
that means that these queer artists
found this space to basically be
creative and to find the means of
production however cheap that was but
also spaces to exhibit this work to be
part of a conversation that in a way is
a conversation that develops that turns
into a conversation that later cinema
will pick up that even Hollywood itself
will end up appropriating after this
period when you look at films like
Midnight Cowboy you know in the late
1960s and other films in the 70s and 80s
they're being influenced by both what's
being produced aesthetically but also
the approach to queer subjectivity in
this earlier cinema so this is a course
that is basically focused on as I'm
calling at this queer avant-garde during
this period it starts in 45 because that
is the end of the war and that's when a
number of these young filmmakers start
to make the films and ends in 1968 and I
used 1968 because this is the moment
when Andy Warhol is shot by by radical
lesbian feminist
who wrote a manifesto called scum and
Jack Smith basically stops making
experimental films and moves into
experimental theater and Kenneth Anger
also is basically at the end of his very
creative realm so to think about why
1968 becomes this kind of key year when
this queer energy shuts down
interestingly a year before Stonewall
and the rise of kind of a new gay and
lesbian energy that arises at this time
period well I also teach in film studies
my position is in film studies American
Studies and LGBT studies so I do teach
courses that are basically a close
analysis of film aesthetics so I teach
the introduction to film studies course
for in for instance and one of the
pleasures I get is you know studying a
film how its put together how meaning is
constructed through every choice that a
filmmaker makes and that can be you know
again costume sets
color you know where the camera is
located you know whether it's a close-up
or an extreme long shot why these
choices are being made and how that
changes the meaning and I basically
bring that into the introduction to
queer cinema and the post-war queer
avant-garde cinema klore course so
within those
courses that I'm teaching for LGBT
studies I'm also teaching a sense of
close analysis and thinking about how
these elements of aesthetics or
narrative construction actually can
construct a queer aesthetic what you can
do differently in the choices that you
make that seem to be speaking from maybe
a sort of queer interior tee or a queer
experience of the world so I think that
actually there's a nice parallel between
what I'm teaching in intro to film with
the queer studies courses
I'm also along with the duties of
programming being on the LGBT studies
committee I chair a committee that is
actually given a small amount of money
to build up the collection of films DVDs
and other media related material for the
film Study Center and and for also the
library at large and so lately because
of the amount of money that I've been
given to do this that this committee has
been given to do this we have found that
we can buy all the DVDs that we want and
there's still money left over so we've
been actually building up the film
collection the 35 millimeter and 16
millimeter film collection at the film
Study Center building up the archive of
LGBT material that can be used in the
classroom and also for film series and
just this year for instance we bought
35-millimeter print of Pedro almodóvar
Matador we were given a 35-millimeter
print of the recent film pariah
with help from an alum Lisa Cortes we've
been building up the 16-millimeter
collection of of the Canon including the
Children's Hour a 1961 film a 1965 film
adaptation of Mary McCarthy's the group
some television dramas really important
from the 1970s again
16-millimeter a question of love with
Gena Rowlands and Jane Alexander a
really important made-for-television
movie which actually is not available on
video so it's a very rare copy what
we've been able to purchase and sixty
millimeter copy of rope and other films
so we are in a really wonderful position
at at Yale and having this support for
again building this material for both
present but also future scholarship for
both undergraduates and graduate
students